a muscle filters about 20 to 25 liters  of water per day so there's a lot of  water coming in that water contains my  plastics this portion of Marcus's  contains about 90 particles of plastic  we've estimated that a Belgium would eat  anything between two thousand and eleven  thousand micro part of particles per  year yes our children will be eating  even more as plastics accumulate in the  ocean by the end of the century  Europeans are likely to be consuming as  many as three quarters of a million  pieces of plastic every year using all  the knowledge we know and common sense  tells me if we continue doing this we  will at one point sooner or later  reach the threshold where there will be  effect so that's that's why we need to  do something about it now